[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición de enlace
centroamérica desde panamá país que ha
sido protagonista de una serie de
protestas las más grandes de los últimos
30 años lideradas por gremios y
sindicatos de diferentes sectores además
de grupos indígenas los cierres de su
principal arteria vial fueron la
característica de unas manifestaciones
que reclamaron fundamentalmente la
disminución de los precios de la
gasolina los alimentos y las medicinas
tras semanas de bloqueos los productores
agrícolas y comerciantes comenzaron a
verse afectados y los alimentos y la
gasolina es casi en algunas zonas del
país
las dos primeras semanas de cierre de
vías por las protestas generaron impacto
directo en una parte del sector
productivo del país cerca de 500
millones de dólares en pérdidas sólo en
la agroindustria los cierres en varios
puntos de una carretera de más de 700
kilómetros que conecta a toda la nación
fue una medida de presión de quienes
permanecieron en las calles este es el
gremio docente bloqueando las vías al
igual que otros sectores sindicatos y
grupos indígenas su presencia en las
calles había sido permanente su
descontento se mantuvo vigente después
que rechazaron las primeras propuestas
del ejecutivo para tratar de apaciguar
el reclamo social nosotros nos
mantenemos en la calle como fuerza de
presión ante el constante injusticia que
existe en nuestro país lo que es el tema
de la desigualdad la corrupción que está
ahogando al pueblo panameño
especialmente y principal a los sectores
más vulnerables de este país del otro
lado de estas manifestaciones una parte
de la población sitio sus efectos
esteban comercializa sus productos
vegetales en el principal mercado
mayorista de la capital panameña son
alimentos que además se producen en la
provincia de chiriquí en un área
agrícola a más de 500 kilómetros de
ciudad de panamá y los bloqueos cortaron
el suministro regular de los comestibles
y tardó 8 días
ocho días tuve que botar toda la basura
en fresa perdido cualquiera cantidad
solamente en la fresa para no decirte
brócoli lechuga las lechugas hidropónica
y todo estos productos no son de allá
para allá es un producto perecedero y
que ha costado sembrar lo durante
cuidarlo abonarlo durante tres meses y
con el coste de producción y venir lo a
tirar a la basura es eso un pecado eso
duele mucho la verdad que estamos
heridos y nos están poniendo la rodilla
no es justo a pesar de la instalación de
una mesa de dialogo con el gobierno los
sectores en protesta decidieron
permanecer en las calles mientras esto
ocurría al sector privado del país
solicitaba su inclusión al diálogo por
considerar que lo que se discutía los
afectaba directamente a ellos para
algunos estos pueden ser la continuación
de una ola de protestas que ha sido
visible en toda la región durante los
últimos tiempos sin embargo dentro del
país hay una valoración distinta donde
la pandemia y la guerra en ucrania
pueden haber contribuido pero hay otros
factores en los últimos 50 años panamá
ha vivido otras dos grandes olas de
protestas en 1979 educativa fue el punto
de partida de casi dos meses de
manifestaciones más tarde en 1987
comenzó la reacción ciudadana contra la
dictadura de manuel antonio noriega
quien fue sacado del poder dos años
después luego de esa etapa se desarrolló
una infraestructura económica según los
analistas la improvisación fragmentación
política justicia fallida corrupción y
derroche que acumulados han generado la
reacción de discrepancia de estos
sectores de la población una reacción de
rabia de dígito de no tolerancia los
errores que antes se toleraban ahora ya
no
y algunas figuras del estado
cometieron el error de
ostentar sus errores
y esa ostentación costaron reacciones
violentas en mayo de 2022 ya una parte
del país había demostrado inconformidad
por la situación económica la provincia
de colon con una infraestructura
portuaria y comercial además de tener la
ruta atlántica del canal de panamá
estuvo paralizada por varias semanas
todo coincide con la mayor inflación de
panamá en varios años los precios del
combustible se incrementaron en forma
constante la primera mitad del año
alcanzando un valor 50% superior a
diciembre de 2021 la inflación acumulada
hasta junio era de 4.4 por ciento el
país no presentaba una inflación
superior al 2% en los últimos siete años
siendo panamá uno de los países con la
mayor tasa de crecimiento anual en la
región con 15.3 por ciento en el año
además en la última década al producto
interno per cápita en el país pasó de 9
mil 358 dólares a 12 mil 200 dólares sin
embargo la nación centroamericana sigue
siendo uno de los países más desiguales
de la región yo creo que panamá tiene
suficientes recursos
para poder atender esa desigualdad y a
mi parecer la desigualdad está
apuntalada por la
la pobrísima
educación en panamá en adición a
y modelos de servicios de servicios
públicos que también están desfasados en
el tiempo para los analistas hay tres
elementos que deben ser fundamentales
para evitar que esté descontento se
repita nuevamente que el gobierno se
apoye en la mayor cantidad de grupos
dentro del país incluso adversarios
políticos para garantizar un clima de
paz así como entender las demandas
colectivas y diseñar una estrategia
urgente de generación de puestos de
trabajo gracias por acompañarnos en este
enlace centroamérica desde panamá soy
oscar sulbarán y les invito a seguir con
france24 en español